On May 30th 1938, accountant Carl Wilkes married
Crysilda Berryman in Bakersfield, CA.
Just one year later, they gave birth to their
son, Paul Emery Wilkes, but on April 1st 1943,
they would return to the Bakersfield Receiving
Hospital, this time to deliver a daughter.
But this was no April Fools joke.
Annie Wilkes is main antagonist of Stephen
King’s Misery, a character he created to
represent his fear of his most obsessive fans.
But Annie’s history goes much deeper than
what we see in the film adaptation of Misery,
so stick around to the end of this video to
see me analyse her entire life’s story,
including how she planned to take revenge
on Paul after escaping the house.
This video is sponsored by Raycon.
Quick note: I’ve been doing a lot of serious
looking into the best options for premium
wireless earbuds, and it doesn’t make any
sense to me why anyone would look past The
Raycon Everyday E25 earbuds.
They have the perfect fit for your ears and
deliver that top notch, clean, isolated sound
quality that you’d expect from the top brands
on the market.
I’m gonna get back to the video right now,
but I just don’t get why you would spend
200 dollars or more when you could use my
link right now to get Raycons and you’ll
be getting better battery life [6 hours of
playtime] and great color options.
Visit buy raycon dot com slash czsworld to
get that deal.
[HORROR HISTORY]
As a young girl, Annie loved going to the
movies with her brother, and her favorite
part was always the chapter plays.
In the 1940s, television was not yet widespread,
and the internet did not yet exist, so feature
films were accompanied by newsreels and serials,
or as Annie called them, chapter plays.
Her favorite series was called Rocketman.
Well, it may have actually been called King
of the Rocket Men.
Annie’s memory tends to be a bit spotty.
She loved the cliffhangers at the end of each
episode, and would spend the week thinking
about how Rocketman would get out of his latest
dilemma.
In one episode, Rocketman was stuck in a car
with no brakes, that went over a cliff, bursted
into flames and fell into the ocean.
The next week, Annie was there early to see
how it turned out, but was furious to see
Rocketman jump out of the car just before
it went off the cliff.
"I stood right up and started shouting.
This isn't what happened last week.
Have you all got amnesia?
They just cheated us.
This isn't fair!
He didn’t get out of the cockadoodie car!!”
She wouldn't stop yelling about how that wasn’t
what happened last week, to the point that
the manager threatens to kick her out.
This incident tells us two things about Annie.
First, it highlights her obsessive attitude
towards works of fiction, a problem that will
only intensify as she gets older and discovers
new stories to latch onto.
Second, it shows the early signs of borderline
personality disorder, commonly known as bi
polar.
She’s sitting there excited for the movie
one minute, and causing a scene the next;
she has no control over her emotions and mood
swings.
Annie was also a long time sugar-junkie, maybe
another sign of her lack of self discipline.
She sometimes babysat for a woman who lived
in her building named Mrs. Kremitz, but she didn’t
like the four kids, and called them the brats.
On October 28th 1954, when Annie was 11, her
family was staying in a temporary house because
of a water leak in the apartment, and Annie
went back and started a fire in the basement,
killing five people, including the brats she
had to babysit.
This was an extreme response, showing us that
Annie’s views on other people were very
black and white.
She either liked someone, and practically
worshipped them, or deemed them as bad, and
felt they didn’t deserve to live.
There was very little in between.
Unfortunately for her father Carl Wilkes,
he fell into the latter category.
On July 19th, 1957, he passed away at 44 years
of age.
Newspapers reported him stumbling on a pile
of clothing, but it’s heavily implied that
his 14 year old daughter had something to
do with it.
"Come here."
"DAD!"
The next incident came January 29th 1962.
Annie was in her sophomore year at USC’s
nursing school, when her roommate Andrea St.
James was taken out in a similar manner -- she
had supposedly tripped on their cat, which
was lying on the stairs, ending her life at
21 years of age.
It was discovered that the cat had also been
poisoned, but that didn’t seem suspicious
because the landlord had put out rat traps
in the basement, and figured the cat had gotten
into them.
Perhaps one of the most disturbing parts about
Annie’s minimum of 8 victims before even
graduating from college, is the fact that
there was a sense of pride she associated
with her accomplishments.
She collected newspaper articles for each
of the obituaries she was responsible for,
and secretly kept them in her scrapbook, often
looking back at them as her “cherished memories,”
right there with other normal achievements,
like her graduation from nursing school on
May 17, 1966.
She was an honor student.
The first nursing job she held was across
the country in Manchester, NH, where she continued
to collect obituaries at St. Joseph’s Hospital.
Her first victim there was a 79 year old Ernest
Gonyar, followed not long after by Hester
Queeny Builiphant.
There were three deaths that summer, then
two more in the fall of 1969.
So during that year in New Hampshire, she
had nearly doubled her victim count.
I would attribute this to desensitization.
Her attacks in her child and teen years were
very spaced out, but the more she did it,
the more frequent her issues became.
Then once she was in nursing school, she was
around death a lot more, and got even more
used to it.
For most people this wouldn’t be a problem,
but for someone with BPD in addition to a
secret, violent past, it could be considered
an issue.
I would like to point out that the desensitization
I’m talking about is not the same as desensitization
to violence in movies, video games, or other
media, which has been proven to have no link
to real world violence.
Each of her hospital victims were older people
whose deaths were attributed to “long illness”,
or in some cases, “short illness.”
Perhaps due to paranoia that people were catching
on, she decided to start fresh in a new town;
a career reboot, if you will.
But like many horror franchises today, Annie’s
life had WAY too many reboots.
Yes, I’m looking at you.
*sad music*
It started on March 19th, 1970, when she was
announced as a new registered nurse at Riverview
Hospital in Harrisburg Pennsylvania.
This was followed by another two patients
that she gave the old “you don't get to
be alive anymore” treatment to.
You know Annie is scary when I’m running
out of words to use that won’t get me in
trouble with YouTube.
It was also in Harrisburg where she took up
karate, and apparently was very good at it.
I would guess that this is also where she
gained a lot of her strength and part of the
reason she’s able to easily carry a fully
grown man when she’s in her mid 40s.
Annie also took up a hobby in collecting ceramic
figurines.
Her last victim in Harrisburg was a 3 year
old who had fallen down a well and was already
in a coma, so it didn’t look that suspicious
that Annie was "unable to save the kid".
At this point she basically got into a cycle;
she’d get a job in a new city, collect two
or three new victims and move on before anyone
started to catch on to what she was up to.
But the reason she didn’t stay may not have
just been because of her growing list of victims.
She was also secretly stealing medication,
and stashing it for her own personal use.
“But I knew enough not to take any of the
morphine-based drugs.
They lock those up.
They count.
They keep records.
And if they get an idea that a nurse is, you
know, chipping—that’s what they call it—they
watch that nurse until they’re sure.”
The non-canon fan series Castle Rock suggests
that she stole medications to relieve her
hallucinations, but there’s no confirmation
of that in the novel.
Her pattern continued until 1978, when she
started a job at the Denver Receiving Hospital.
Annie’s first victim in Denver was a woman
named Laura Rothberg, in September of 1978,
but the next headline would not be an obituary,
but rather…
a marriage announcement?
Ralph Dugan was a physical therapist at Arapahoe
County Hospital, and according to Paul Sheldon,
he looked a lot like Annie Wilkes’s father.
Marrying a parent like figure has come up
before in King’s writing, I discussed similar
relationships when analyzing characters like
Beverly Marsh and Eddie Kaspbrak.
Annie relocated an hour Northwest to the small
town of Nederland where Ralph’s hospital
was located.
Together, they bought a house in Sidewinder
on March 3rd, 1979 and during the time she
was with Ralph, she didn’t add any obituaries
to her collection.
Someone with Borderline Personality Disorder
may try to use a relationship as a source
of comfort from their symptoms, the same way
that struggling people might turn to drugs
or alcohol, so I think this might have contributed
to her break period from the violence.
Unfortunately, Ralph was a physical therapist,
not a mental one, so leaning on a relationship
was probably not a healthy way to deal with
her issue.
Kimberly Holland writes on Healthline, that
even common BPD symptoms can be detrimental
to a relationship, and that these endeavors
are often short lived.
Ralph and Annie lasted only a year and a half,
and on August 3rd, 1980, Ralph filed for divorce
on the grounds of mental cruelty.
Paul suggests that Ralph might have realized
her true nature, and luckily gotten out of
there while he still had his life.
Another note on the BPD in relationships article
states that “(the person) can become angry
and hurt over something a person without BPD
would not react to.
They can even become obsessive.”
However, as far as we can tell, Annie does
not necessarily become obsessive about her
ex-husband, but rather, she focuses on her
other true love: fiction.
More specifically, she’s found a new favorite
author.
His name was Paul Sheldon, and Annie adored
his period romance novel series, the Misery
books.
Misery had become her new obsession.
Annie also loved pigs and even named her newest
addition to the barn after Misery’s titular
character.
"Paul, say hello to my favorite beast in the whole world.
My sow, Misery!"
"Oink,  oink, oink."
"Misery."
..and I think after finding out that the author
traditionally finished his novels nearby in
Boulder, Colorado, the object of her obsession
turned from Misery to him and she relocated
her job one last time to a hospital in Boulder.
By the time she started that job in March
1981, she had taken back her maiden name;
Annie Dugan was once again Annie Wilkes.
It would also seem that her anger over the
failed marriage was taken out on her patients
in Boulder, and in 1981, she made up for her
lost time by taking 13 more victims from May
until the end of the year, bringing her total
up over 30.
But the most disgusting of her crimes were
yet to come.
On January 14th, 1982 she was named as the
new head maternity nurse, and it only took
two weeks to extend her tradition onto the
newborn infants that were kept there.
The first incident took place January 29th,
with another that followed not long after.
When Paul eventually reads about the newborn
obituaries in Annie’s scrapbook, he thinks
she probably started only going after babies
with birth defects, and eventually expanded
it to include healthy ones as well.
This theory makes sense, because she at one
point demonstrates to Paul that she believes
in putting creatures out of their misery when
she kills an injured rat, but she laters shows
evidence of a growing taste for violence when
she re-injures Paul after noticing he’s
starting to heal.
In mid-March there are five more nursery deaths,
and this time an investigation is launched.
"We are going to be launching an investigation into what happened.
I told them that we were launching an investigation.
*laughter*
Previously she was always able to get away
before her actions were investigated, but
this time she wasn’t able to do so, and
I can see two reasons.
First, the fact that she was dealing with
infants this time as opposed to elderly people.
It’s not THAT unusual for an elderly person
to get sick and pass away, and while newborns
are lost from time to time, it doesn’t make
sense for so many healthy babies to kick the bucket.
The second reason goes back to her short lived
marriage with Ralph.
It’s much easier to pick up and leave unexpectedly
if you’re renting an apartment, but since
she owned the house now, it would be much
harder to move, not to mention, more suspicious.
But the amazing part about this junction in
her history, is that the investigation didn’t
discourage her from continuing.
On March 24th, she made a statement on behalf
of the hospital, saying that the culprit may
have been tainted baby formula, but in April,
another infant hit zero HP and in May two
more little chonkers took dirt naps instead
of nursery naps.
By June 1st, they were closing in on Annie,
and she underwent questioning by her own free
will.
They eventually let her go, and maybe that
close call got her to back off temporarily,
because there were no infant cases in June,
but she started back up again in early July
with three more little tiny funerals.
On July 19th, Annie was arrested for the murder
of Girl Christopher, one of the victims that
actually lived long enough to be given a name.
Annie was given a nickname by the press, The
Dragon Lady, because of the nature of the
situation where the entire village was basically
after her with torches and pitchforks.
The best evidence against her was a handmark
on the child’s throat with what seemed to
be the mark of Annie’s ring.
The jury made their verdict on December 13th,
and in the newspaper was a photograph of Annie
quietly reading her copy of Misery’s Quest
inside her holding cell.
The Dragon Lady was found innocent, much to
the dismay of the town.
She parted ways with the hospital, putting
an end to what would be her last job, but
that did not mean that she’d put out her
last victim.
In late 1983 she picked up a hitchhiker named
Andrew Pomeroy on her way back from a ceramics
show.
Pomeroy told her he was headed to Sidewinder
on assignment from a magazine in New York;
he was to go make some sketches of the ruins
of a place called the Overlook Hotel, which
had been burned down 10 years beforehand by
a crazy caretaker.
Those who have read The Shining will be familiar
with this location.
There are often cross-references to other
stories in King’s writing, but this connection
could share a deeper meaning.
Misery is almost like a sister or companion
piece to The Shining.
Both stories feature authors working on a
new project who suffer from the psychological
effects of isolation, while stranded in Sidewinder,
Colorado.
The big difference is that The Shining is
a ghost story, while Misery has no direct
references to anything supernatural at all,
however there are many scenes where Paul and
Annie try to get into each other’s head
and figure out what the other one is thinking,
though it's not evident that either one is
successful in the mind reading tactic know
as 'shining'.
There’s also something interesting about
the weapon of choice in each respective story.
In the book, Annie uses and axe, but in the
movie she uses a mallet -- whereas in The
Shining it’s a mallet in the book, but an
axe in the movie.
Pomeroy ends up staying at Annie’s house,
where, according to her, they were lovers,
despite him being 18 years younger at the
age of 22.
However, it was bad news for him when Annie
found out he’d been lying about working
for the magazine, he was really just planning
to sell the drawings on spec.
She was also critical of his work, which caused
him to laugh at her,
"They're all gonna laugh at you!"
and that may have been
the last straw because Annie gave him the
axe and dumped his body in the frozen streambed,
where it stayed for the entire winter.
Once the stream thawed out, the water carried
his dismembered remains away -- nearly 27
miles -- and he wasn’t found until November
1984, a year after his death.
Annie continued living in relative isolation
with her 6 hens, 2 cows and her pig, Misery.
She did sometimes get complaints about her
yard from her neighbors, The Roidmans, but
it would seem that with no hospital to feed
her new victims, her homicidal days were behind
her, but in February 1987, she would discover
a golden opportunity.
On a stormy day in mid-to-late February, Annie
went into town to get groceries and check
if the paperbacks of the new Paul Sheldon
book, Misery’s Child, were in yet.
While her copy of the book was not ready yet,
she would get something much better.
And I’m not talking about the audiobook.
She ended up coming across a car crash, and
because of her nursing background, she can
tell that the victim has the will to live
based on the quality of his screams.
Now in the movie she eventually admits that
she was stalking Paul when the accident occurred;
that’s not the case in the book, but I do
like to think that she knew of his tradition
of finishing his books at the Boulderado Hotel
and maybe went out of her way to go past there.
The CPR she administered probably saved his
life, but because of her obsessive fandom,
she makes the decision not to do the right
thing by bringing him to the hospital, but
instead, back to her house, where she planned
to take care of him on her own.
Annie already considered herself his number
one fan.
She had taken a liking to his work immediately
when she discovered it.
But because this is where the story starts,
this is where we can shift our focus from
Annie’s Borderline Personality Disorder
to another classification, Celebrity Worship
Syndrome.
I’m not a fan of that acronym.
But unlike BPD, Celebrity Worship Syndrome
isn’t officially recognized by the National
Institute of Mental Health, but remember these
disorders are just ways for us to describe
a pattern of mental behavior, it’s not quite
the same as say, a virus which has physical
particles that we can identify.
But there is still legit research on Celebrity
Worship Syndrome, with studies linking it
to increased levels of anxiety and depression.
Both of those are also symptoms of Borderline
Personality Disorder, which obviously led
me to speculate that in Annie's case the two
are linked, and I’ll discuss that link later
on in her story.
Mr. Sheldon falls into a respiratory depression,
so Annie had him on pain medication and fed
him through an IV.
A week and a half later she went into town
where she was finally able to get her copy
of Misery's Child.
"Paul Sheldon writes the Misery novels. They're very good. I'm looking for the latest one.
Misery's Child. I really need that to complete my collection.
And I really think you need to have that here!
Misery!"
"I don't have it in the store but I could probably order it for you."
"I'm not interested in waiting.
What kind of cockadoodie bookstore is this?
How can ANY of you BE in a BOOKSTORE when you don't know PAUL SHELDON?
"I AM LOOKING FOR A COCKADOODIE BOOOOOKKKK!!!!!!!!!"
"...I can order it for you."
...and 2 weeks after the crash she greeted
him as he finally came to.
As part of her plan, she kept him on a pain
medication Noveryl, which worked to her advantage
because it made him drowsy so that he was
easy to control.
She knowingly gets him hooked so that even
as he regained his strength, he would always
need to stick around to get his fix of Noveryl.
She also finds the manuscript for his next
novel, Fast Cars, in his bag and asks if she
can read it.
When he allows her, she accidentally lets
this confession slip.
“I love you Paul.
I mean, your mind.
Your creativity.
That's all I meant.”
This is another possible symptom of the Celebrity Worship
Disorder, commonly referred to as Love Obsessional,
where the person may convince themselves that
they are in love with the celebrity despite
not actually knowing them.
This famously happened when a woman convinced
herself she was the wife of talk show host
David Letterman for five years, or perhaps
even more cringefully, a man with a YouTube
account who publicly released a happy birthday
video for Bridgette West from the Angry Grandpa
Show where he basically asks her to leave
her boyfriend for him.
Gotta roll it.
"Bridgette West.
If you liked what you saw, please subscribe to my YouTube channel.
Also, in case you're wondering, the original inspiration to make it look like I'm interested in you,
was a vlog back in June called Pickle Boy and Bridgette Break Up.
But I understand that it will humiliated Michael if you really do break up with him.
But it's your choice.
EEEE….
Giving Annie Wilkes a run for her money there
my man.
Annie reads 40 pages of the manuscript for
Fast Cars, and criticizes it.
In particular, she’s not a fan of the use
of profanity, and it causes her to smash Paul’s
soup bowl against the wall.
I honestly think this moment is way ahead
of its time, because it demonstrates a rather
new symptom of her disorder, which I’ll
just call toxic fandom.
Annie is upset that Paul is straying from
writing the type of novel that she wants him
to write.
Just in the last couple years, we’ve seen
this happen with several franchises.
Fans start to think that they know better than
the artists, they demand a “return to form”
and then the artist either decides to stay the
course, or cave into the fans’ demands.
Once in a blue moon, the fan imposed changes actually
end up working out for the better, but it’s
really not worth sacrificing all the original
ideas that have been, and probably will continue
to be thrown out thanks to this trend.
I’m not saying fan feedback is always a
bad thing, but when suggestions turn into
demands, threats, and thinking they know best,
that’s where it crosses over into disease
territory.
And I’d rather have an artist try something
new and fail than pander to the masses, which
almost never yields an interesting product.
Modern fans use social media to wage warfare
on the artists they follow, but Annie’s
method of manipulation involved withholding
his pain medication all afternoon and eventually
making him wash the pills down with rinse
water.
Then, the next morning, she repeats her behaviour
after reading about her favorite character’s
death at the end of Misery’s Child.
She throws another tantrum, where she destroys
a water pitcher and decides to leave to get
a hold of herself away from Paul.
She goes to a property she refers to as her
“laughing place”, an upcountry getaway
inspired by the old childrens’ stories of
Brer Rabbit and Brer Fox.
At one point, she explains, “Sometimes I
do laugh when I go there.
But mostly I just scream.”
While she was there, she prayed to God, and
when she left the laughing place two days
later, she had the idea that she was supposed
to show Paul the error of his past by making
him burn his manuscript.
She also gets the idea to give him the chance
to redeem himself by forcing him to write
a new book, so on the way back she stops in
town and purchases a typewriter and some paper.
She bargains with the shop owner, Nancy Dartmonger,
about the price, because the typewriter is
missing the letter N.
She brings her charcoal grill into the room
and withholds Paul’s food and medication
until he burns Fast Cars, which he does after
putting up a struggle.
That afternoon she sets up a workstation and
tells him to write a new novel just for her
called Misery’s Return, which was to be
her payment for nursing him.
Of course, Paul doesn’t have any intention
of writing another Misery novel, but he doesn't really
have a choice -- he needs Annie’s
medical help if he wants to survive, and the
situation is representative of what any artist
has to go through in dealing with these crazy
fans.
For most artists, they have to balance what
they want to do and what the fans want them
to do to survive… that is, to make money
through their craft while still expressing
themselves.
In Paul’s case, the survival aspect is much
more literal.
Annie also tries to manipulate him into going
with her plan by lying and saying he should
be healthy enough to go out and meet people
again by the time he’s done.
What she’s really doing is sending a subtle
threat, a “do what I say if you want any
chance at surviving.”
The next morning she shakes Paul awake to
serve his breakfast, excited for him to start
her masterpiece.
Paul asks that she give him a different type
of paper to work on, one that doesn’t smudge.
He tries to give her the idea that there are
a lot more complications in the writing business
than she knows about, and I find it interesting
that Annie doesn’t like hearing Paul call
it a business.
In the same way she can’t see that people
have both good and bad qualities, she also
refuses to acknowledge that her favorite novels
are written for both art and profit.
And as you’re about to find out, the same concept
also applies to YouTube videos.
After throwing a fit over his request, but
returning from town with the new packs of
paper, Annie returns to find Paul in a sweating,
shivering state.
This gives her the earliest suspicion that
he’d been trying to escape, but she’s
able to dispel the thought when he tells her
he’s just been suffering because of the
lack of pain medication.
The occurrence would, however, trigger her
paranoia.
She had initially begun experiencing paranoia
when she felt the whole town was out to get
her during the Dragon Lady trial, so she would
put herself on high alert, which was dangerous
for Paul.
Her suspicions are heightened again when she
notices that one of her ceramic figures in
the parlor had been moved.
And she wonders if Paul had somehow been out of
the room, but again, begins to second guess
herself, thinking that she may have been the one to do it herself.
She double checks to make sure she still had
the only key to his door, and she did, but
she still thought that he maybe had found
another way out, and her years working as
a nurse had taught her to always check her
maybes.
So she looks in the downstairs bathroom, where
all the medication she’d chipped from her
various hospital jobs was kept.
Again, she had the sense that stuff had been
stirred around, but couldn’t be sure that
she hadn’t moved anything herself, so she
decides not to say anything yet, but keep
one eye open for more activity.
The sequence demonstrates that she may be
crazy, but she still has her wits about
her, and could be even more dangerous because
of her cleverness.
But two days later, she had been unable to
find more evidence that Paul had left the
room, so she was about to drop the idea until
she came in to give him his Noveryl one afternoon
and felt the doorknob get stuck.
When she opened it, she heard something rattle
inside the lock -- but again, she shows her
cleverness by not overreacting until she was
sure.
This is because if he was sneaking around,
she didn’t want him to know she was on to him.
She was better off keeping it a secret so
that Paul would continue to be careless and
possibly leave more evidence behind, thus
making it less likely he'd be able to one
day sneak away.
It was a constant mind game between the two
of them.
So when she heard the lock rattle, she gave
him his pills like normal, and acted like
nothing was wrong.
But again, she was back on high alert, so
that afternoon, when she helped him into his
wheelchair she realized for the first time
that he was more lively.
He was able to move his legs more and his
arms were stronger.
She had discovered that he had been hiding
his recovery, and thought that he too was
good at keeping secrets.
So that night she countered with a move of
her own by giving him a stronger medication
than usual to keep him asleep as she removed
the keyplate from the door and discovered
the bobby pin that he’d used as his key.
That’s when she also noticed black marks
on the doorframe, as if he’d bumped the
wheelchair into it while trying to get through.
Again, she decides it’s too early to confront
him and it’s better if he thinks she’s
oblivious.
A couple days later, now past the three-week
mark of her kidnapping him, he’s written
the first chapter of Misery’s Return, but
Annie rejects it for the same reason she detested
the cliff car resolution in Rocketman all
those years ago, because the chapter he came
up with wasn’t consistent with the previous
entry.
As Paul got back to work on a second attempt,
Annie secretly watched him, hoping to gather
more information about his escape plan.
On March 25th, six chapters are complete,
and Annie agrees that they’re fair.
She agrees to read his work chapter by chapter
so she can fill in the Ns that he was unable
to produce with the defective typewriter,
or at least that’s the reason she gives.
The battle between Paul and Annie is a mental
game of chess.
If Annie’s move was to get Paul addicted
to the Noveryl so that he needed her, his
counter-move was to get her addicted to his
writing so she needed him just as much.
It was also on this day that she gave the
only suggestion about the story she would
ever give, giving him the idea that maybe
one of the characters had not died, but had
actually fallen into a coma induced by a bee-sting.
Annie seems very embarrassed to give any input,
which is a strange touch because of the control
she has over the situation.
It shows Paul that she’s still very sensitive
when it comes to the book, and allows him
to take one of the few advantages that he
can over her.
But this small win for Paul would be short
lived.
Annie hears a car pulling up to her house,
and quickly goes to get her handcuffs and
the only thing she can find to silence him,
a dust rag.
She locks her prisoner in place and stuffs
the rag in his mouth, not bothering to take
the taste of the chemicals left over on it
into consideration.
Even though she felt that she had prevented
Paul from getting the man’s attention, she
also had to prevent the man from noticing
Paul, since the room does have a window.
So she walks him up the driveway to angle
off his possible line of sight.
The guy gives her a document that tells her
that she has an overdue property tax payment,
and she explodes on him with anger, even though
the guy was actually doing her a courtesy
by notifying her.
She’s still fuming when she comes back inside,
and Paul helps calm her down by explaining
it to her and offering to pay the fee with
the money left inside of his wallet.
Annie had basically just forgotten to pay
this fee, one of many examples of her losing
track of small tasks, like how she forgets
to turn the calendar page in Paul’s room,
and this isn’t a symptom of the two disorders
we’ve already discussed, but it does show
us that she’s slowly experiencing an overall
mental degradation.
With Paul’s help, she’s able to go into
town that day and take care of the tax.
From March 25th to April 15th, they have routine
going, where Paul would work on the novel
and Annie would mostly work on maintaining
her yard in order to give nobody a reason
to bother her.
She also cooked and cleaned, she would bring
him dinner at 5PM and afterwards roll in a
black and white television so they would watch
MASH or WKRP.
Maybe even some Mukbang videos
Nah.
Not even Annie Wilkes would watch that.
When
it got warmer she would take him out onto
the back porch for some fresh air.
But on April 15th, her good spirits came crashing
back down, and despite the date, this one
was not tax related.
The main symptom associated with BPD is huge
mood swings, and when this happens, victims
are more vulnerable for self-harm and self-destruction.
On this day, Annie’s mood was swinging like
a 2015 Javier Baez.
We don’t know exactly how she got into such
a bad state but she’s described as having
a bloody lip, looking like a mess and having
some kind of goo spilled all over her.
From what I can gather, maybe she was making
breakfast, spilled on herself, got really
depressed and literally beat herself up over
it.
She threw Paul his pills, and when asked if
she was OK, she responded, “no”.
She left him to go sit down in the parlor,
where she repeatedly slapped herself loud
enough for Paul to hear from his room.
For a manic-depressive person like Annie,
this was the first sign she was about to slip
into a deep period of depression, which not
only included hurting herself, but also unhealthy
binge eating that mirrors her lack of self
control when it comes to the consumption of
fiction, which comes up again later.
I think this also brought back some of her
paranoia about Paul escaping, and the idea
of losing the man she thought she loved made
her even more depressed.
So she ended up spying on him all morning
through the keyhole in the door, which is
representative of another toxic practice seen
in those with Celebrity Worship Syndrome -- something
that we’ve seen quite a lot in recent years
with YouTube celebrities: invasion of privacy.
There has long been an issue for celebrities
-- where paparazzi would try to capture every
detail of their lives, and while I don’t
think invading the private portion of someone’s
life is ever a good thing, we’ve seen it
change from celebrity obsessed individuals
simply being the market for tablet magazines,
to people tracking down celebrities’ home
addresses and showing up themselves, or worse,
setting a horrible example for their kids
by bringing them to ambush their favorite
creators at home.
Back in the day with traditional media celebrities
it was an issue, but less of an issue, because
they could just hire private security and
they were protected.
But now with YouTube and TikTok, we have a
lot of very young people who become very famous
without the wealthiness that used to come
with it.
So… you know… the merch store is always...
open…
The reason I bring that up with Paul is he
has to deal with something similar.
He is rich, but because he’s at the mercy
of his captor, he has no way of protecting
his privacy against Annie, and she sees him
through the keyhole, getting into his wheelchair
to write and confirming her suspicions about
him faking how weak he really was.
This would lead to another outburst where
Annie’s willingness to let him live comes
to an end.
Before confronting her disobedient prisoner
again, Annie goes down into the basement to
clear out the rat traps, because it had been
rainy, and the rats tend to come into the
cellar when it rains.
She finds one that is injured, but still alive
and brings it up when she goes to see Paul.
The reason she does this is to draw the comparison
between Paul’s situation and the rat’s
-- they are both captives of Annie, and because
of their injuries, they’re unable to escape.
She explains that a rat in a trap thinks it
wants to live.
“As we do, Paul.
As we do.
We think we know so much, but we really don’t
know any more than a rat in a trap—a rat
with a broken back that thinks it still wants
to live.”
Notice the wording -- she’s including herself
in that too, because she’s aware of her
severe depression that is making her miserable
as well.
She crushes the rat in her hand, and likewise,
offers to get her gun and do the same to Paul
and then herself.
Paul’s only saving grace is to say he first
wants to finish the book, and she agrees that’s
the only thing she still wants to see, and
she mindlessly licks the rat’s blood off
her fingers as she spoke, which is pretty
disgusting, and I think it’s there to show
us how comfortable Annie is with carnage and
make her threat feel that much more real and
scary.
Before leaving, she wants to keep track of
if Paul is moving around the house while she’s
gone.
She plucks out several hairs from her head
and tapes them up around the house, on doors,
on her scrap book that documents all of her
victims, cabinets, drawers and more.
This way she could check which threads were
broken when she got back and theoretically
see exactly where Paul had been and what he
had gone through.
She goes off to her Laughing Place again,
and again, does more praying than laughing.
Because of the snow she has to put chains
on her tires to get back down the road.
She leaves to come back on April 17th, even
though the conditions were very dangerous,
but she was not afraid, thinking God would
guide her.
I’m guessing that she has not seen Carrie.
She almost slid off the road twice, at one
point going all Time Traveler at Silver Dollar
City and doing a full 360° spin while traveling
down the slope.
Then around midnight, her car got stuck in
a snowbank, but she was lucky enough to get
a hand from a public works crew that was able
to free her.
So she probably was quite confident that God
actually was guiding her on this trip.
She stopped off on Route 9 to see if she could
see Paul’s crashed car, but it was gone,
which was a relief for her because she wouldn’t
have to worry about anyone finding it and
coming to look for him for a while longer.
She finally made it back at 4AM, and finds
her victim fast asleep.
She comes back and inspects everywhere she
had set up her hairs, finding many of the
threads broken, proving that Paul had been
around the house.
She also checks upstairs on her dresser, which
would have been impossible for Paul to reach
with his broken legs, and finds that her hairs
have supposedly been completely removed.
It could be that they just weren’t set up
perfectly and they fell away on their own,
but I would guess that it could be related
to her aforementioned memory problems -- she
probably planned to set up the threads on her dresser
but never actually did, but because she knew
he’d been out of the room, she blames him
for that as well.
She also realizes the butcher knife in the
kitchen was missing, so while he’s asleep
she searches around under the bed, where she
finds that, and some pills he’d been storing
there.
This came as a surprise to her, and she must
have decided that she had seen enough.
She had to put and end to his rummaging around
before he found a way to get an upper hand.
To do so she turned to a technique originating
in South Africa.
As Paul woke up that morning she injected
him with a pre-op shot.
She reveals that she found the bobby pin he
used to escape the first time, the broken
threads, and the butcher’s knife, which
she angrily throws into the wall, where it
sticks like a dart.
She explains that Paul’s tricks won’t
fly by her, she’s been a nurse for 10 years.
This is another example of her memory issues
or her losing her mind, because if you were
paying attention in the beginning of this
video, you may remember she became nurse in
1966, which was 21 years beforehand.
She asks how many times he’d left the room.
He insists it was 3 times, but she believes
it’s more.
“I guess fellows like you must get so used
to lying for a living that you just can’t
stop doing it in real life.
But that’s all right, Paul.
Because the principle doesn’t change if
you were out seven times, or seventy, or seventy
times seven.
The principle doesn’t change, and neither
does the response.”
The seventy times seven thing is not another
Brand New reference cause they didn’t exist
yet, but rather a biblical reference towards
the belief in an eternal forgiveness from
God, who is supposed to forgive a man’s
sins not seven times, not seventy times seven
times, but always.
So Annie is basically saying, she doesn’t
care how many times Paul has been out, she’s
still gonna punish him with a process called
hobbling.
"Paul, do you know about the early days at the Kimberly Diamond Mines?
Do you know what they did to the native workers who stole diamonds?
If they caught them, they had to make sure they could go on working.
But they also had to make sure they could never run away.
The operation was called hobbling."
She plans to dismember his foot using very
makeshift tools.
She has a bottle of Betadine to disinfect
the wound, which she slathers over his leg,
then brings out the axe.
She also has a freaking propane torch (!) That
didn’t make the movie.
She chops the axe down into his ankle, causing
excruciating pain, but Annie, after taking
out over 40 people in her lifetime showed
no sympathy and she reared back again to cut
clean through his ankle.
That’s where the blow torch comes in -- she
uses that to burn his stump to a crisp, thus
cauterizing the wound.
This causes the bedsheet to catch fire, and
she’s prepared with a bucket of water to
dump over everything.
It seems that Annie then started to realize
how dangerous her barbaric torture method was.
She told him he’d be fine, even as he was
screaming from the worst pain imaginable,
but she sounded nervous as she did so and
seemed to be looking around the room.
I think she realized that the procedure had
come way too close to killing him, and was
worried that she’d never get to read the
end of her book because of it.
This fear kept up for the next week and he
was in a semi-comatose state, and she wouldn’t
allow him to go back to work on the novel
when he started to come out of it, because
she was very nervous that he was on the brink
of death.
When he did go back to his writing she collected
his work at the end of every day, eager to
get her fix of fiction.
If Annie were around today, she would likely
be one of those people who exercise no self
control when it comes to the binge-release
strategy seen on certain streaming platforms,
where an entire season of a show will be released
at once.
Earlier I mentioned that when she went into
the manic-episode, it was accompanied by the
binge-eating of unhealthy snacks, and I briefly
mentioned that it shows her lack of self control
which is paralleled by her lack of self control
in consuming her favorite media.
So when she comes in to try to bribe Paul
into telling her the entire rest of the story,
it’s no coincidence that she uses ice cream
sundaes to try to do so.
Paul wisely chooses not to tell her the ending
though, since the anticipation for the book was
the only thing keeping him alive.
As the Spring season was winding down Annie
must have been in a particularly bad mental
state, and when she heard Paul complaining
about the missing N key on the typewriter,
she wanted to give him something new to worry
about, and came back with the disinfectant,
a syringe and an electric knife, ready to
perform another “operation”.
After Paul’s complaint about the typewriter,
Annie stormed into the kitchen in another
bi-polar episode.
She was throwing around objects and screaming,
then she came back into the room and jabbed
the syringe into Paul.
It caused him to become drowsy and defenseless,
and once again she poured on the Betadine
and held down his hand as he screamed and
pleaded with her.
After cutting off the thumb with her electric
knife, she took it with her back into the
kitchen and got to work on baking a cake.
This was part of her plan to remind Paul who
was really in charge.
She felt he was getting too comfortable when
he started asking for things again, so this
was her psychotic way of setting the record
straight.
She stuck his loose thumb in the birthday
cake like a candle and brought it into the
room singing Happy Birthday.
Although it was not actually Paul’s birthday,
he got the idea when she told him: “If you
promise to be good Paul you can have a piece
of birthday cake but you won’t have to eat
any of the special candle.”
From there, she only gets weirder and crazier,
which may have had something to do with the
fact that Paul was closing in on finishing
the book and she knew their time was coming
to an end one way or another.
Over a month later, a car appears at her house
before she has the chance to gag Paul again,
and she hears shattering glass and immediately
knows he’s trying to get the person’s
attention.
She grabs a sharpened cross -- you know, something
that almost anyone would have lying around
the house -- and goes out to discover it’s
a police officer.
The guy, whose name was Dywane Kushner, was
stunned to have found Paul and didn’t even
notice Annie before she marched out and stabbed
him in the back and stomach several times,
sending him crashing to the ground.
She leaves him barely alive,
and then comes and finishes the job with her
ridable lawn mower, using it to run over his
arm and head.
"It's the ninth annual Dallas mower expo!
Be there -- ere
As the biggest names in mowers, hedges and clippers -- cutting technology!
Seaking! Oil painintgs. Seaking!
Don't miss the Dallas Mower Expo oscare oops ott
BE THERE! EERRRREEE!!!
Annie spends the afternoon casually cleaning
up the body and erasing any evidence, singing
“She’ll Be Comin’ Round The Mountain”
as she did so.
I kind of wish this was in the movie, because
it shows how doing something so vile can be
a source of happiness for her, and I think
if done right, it would be creepy in the same
way as Jack reciting the Three Little Pigs
nursery rhyme in The Shining.
She knows that eventually more cops will come
looking for Kushner, so she devises a plan
to give Paul a little more time to finish
the novel.
She doesn’t care what happens to her after
that.
She starts by dragging a mattress down to
the cellar and brings Paul down there so that
he can’t alert the police again if they
come back while she goes to hide the police
car at her laughing place.
There’s also an interesting conversation
that takes place with Paul, where we find
out she actually believes she’s not crazy,
she sees herself as a good samaritan because
she saved Paul’s life.
Annie said.
“I was raised better even if you weren’t.
You’re lucky I didn’t cut off your man-gland.
I thought of it, you know.”
YIKES!
She then goes on to explain her entire plan
to him.
She’s gonna hide the car in a shed, bury
the cop and ride her ex-husbands trail bike
to get back.
She’ll leave a note on the door saying she
went off to a ceramics show in Steamboat Heaven,
but if they ask her about it later she’ll
say she slept in her car rather than a hotel
so that nobody asks her to produce receipts.
She also says that she’ll be keeping the
deceased officer’s gun in her purse, so
if Paul tries to scream whenever the cops
do show up, she could reasonably take them
out before they’re able to react.
She does all that the next morning, and the
day after, the cops do show up as expected.
She explains that the first officer came around
looking for Paul right as she was about to
leave, and she told him she did recognize
the man in the photo because it was her favorite
writer.
She also explains that she supposedly offered
the guy a cold Pepsi on his way out, and that
he had taken it with him -- and Annie had
planted a Pepsi bottle with his fingerprints
on it a couple miles up the road to make it
look like he had passed her house safely.
She’s able to send these new cops on their
way without incident, but it wasn’t long
before news broke that the Dragon Lady was
under investigation once again.
Three days later a news crew shows up, which
especially got under Annie’s skin because
the media was probably her least favorite
part when she was on trial in Denver for her
actions as the Head Maternity Nurse.
She fires a warning shot with her gun to scare
them away, but when she comes back in, her
old paranoia about the town being out to get
her returns and sends her into another manic-depressive
episode -- scratching and slapping herself
to the point of drawing blood.
More police show up the next day, and they
inquire about the injuries she’d given herself,
so she tells them she scratched herself during
a bad dream.
Her secret was unraveling, and she predicted
that they’d be back before long with a search
warrant.
The next day gawkers from in town came by
to look at the house, which continued to unnerve
her.
At one point a car full of teenagers comes
onto the driveway to make fun of the Dragon
Lady, and she furiously threatens to shoot
them if they don’t leave.
If only it was the late 2000s, she would have
known all you have to do is tuck in your clothes
and strike a violent pose.
Considering that even just being bothered
by her neighbors, The Roidmans, who lived
down the road got her in a rage before, this
new wave of attention was really getting to
her, but she’s able to get through it when
Paul delivers the good news: Misery’s Return
should be done the next evening.
When the morning of the big day arrived, Annie
excitedly came in to bring him his breakfast
and pain medication just as she had when he
first started the book, so I’m gonna use
the exact same footage right here.
Later that day she brings in a caviar dish in celebration of the
book’s completion.
She had never had caviar before, and when
she tried it, she didn’t like the taste.
I’m not entirely sure how to interpret that
-- it could be King leaving his readers a
clue about who would win and who would lose,
or it could be something deeper than that.
She informs him that when the last word is
written, his favorite bottle of champagne
will be waiting for him -- and he requests
to be allowed to practice one other ritual
he has for finishing a book: smoking his cigarette.
Although she finds smoking to be disgusting,
she allows it as long as she’s out of the
room as he does it.
She’s probably in a charitable mood out
of excitement to finally find out of the story
ends.
She brings the smoke and the match into the
room around noon and leaves him to complete
the book until he calls her in to read the
final chapters.
But as soon as she gets into the room, she
knows something is wrong when she smells lighter
fluid.
She freezes and see Paul holding the lit match
over a soaked stack of papers.
He sets it on fire, and that hurts her more
than anything he could have possibly done
to her, because reading this book was the
only thing she left she had left to live for.
She screamed and rushed to try to put out
the flames, in her delusional state she still
felt some of it could be salvaged.
She keeps saying “Not Misery, Not Misery”
another sign that she was living more in the
fictional world than the real one -- she had
never shown this kind of compassion out care
for any of her victims.
As she’s trying to save the burning pages,
she doesn’t notice Paul lift up the typewriter
and smash it down upon the center of her back.
This knocks her down into the flames, and
she screams even louder as her skin burns.
She hollers at Paul that she’s going to
kill him, but she trips over the typewriter
-- ironically the thing that she cheaped out
on and caused so many issues for Paul, including
the loss of his thumb, was finally coming
back to bite Annie.
He falls on top of her and she struggles to
claw her way out under his weight.
Then he begins to stuff the burning piles
of ash into her mouth, choking her just as
she had nearly choked him with the dust rag.
Eventually she’s able to buck him off of
her, but she ends up tripping on the typewriter
a second time.
I’ve heard of tripping on your words but
this is ridiculous.
This time her head slams against the mantelpiece
and she goes down, knocking her out for some
time.
She comes to and sees Paul trying to get away,
but again, her previous actions come back
to bite her.
She’s unable to hold onto his leg with no
foot to grab onto and he gets away and closes
the door behind him.
But desperate to have her revenge on the man
who killed her Misery not once, but twice,
she makes her way to the door and reaches
her fingers underneath to try to grab his
clothes, but is unsuccessful at holding onto
him and passes out again.
When she wakes up she’s able to remove the
burnt paper from her throat and she has some
time to get ahold of herself and make one
last go at trying to bring Paul down with
her.
She’s pretty sure he’s still in the house
because her car is still there and as far
as she could tell nobody had come to rescue
him.
The doors were also all locked making it very
unlikely that he’d get out on his own.
She jumps out the guest room window and makes
her way to the barn, where she would pick
out a tool to exact her revenge.
She grabs her chainsaw and with it in her
hand, while making her way out the barn, she
collapsed for the final time.
Police later discovered her and determined
that she had succumbed to her fractured skull.
It was the typewriter that had really done
her in.
In the end, Annie would be known by the community
as far more than a stalker fan of a romance
novelist.
The community would eventually discover her
scrapbook and trail of more than 40 crimes.
But to Paul Sheldon, who had dealt with letters
from many obsessed fans in the past, running
into the the craziest of them was his worst
nightmare and for the world famous author
Stephen King, Annie was a combination of every
uncomfortable fan experience wrapped up and
taken to the worst possible scenario.
There are many more characters you have to
understand to have a full grasp of the Stephen
King Universe, so click that playlist on the
left to hear about the histories of his other
characters.
And if you love horror, remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week ring
the deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one, assuming we stay
inside.